welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and one division just officially
crossed over x-men to the marvel
cinematic universe
and no one knows how the hell it
happened or what the hell it means
wanda's brother pietro shows up inside
the west view anomaly played not by the
mcu's aaron taylor johnson quicksilver
whose character died in avengers age of
ultron but by evan peters
who played max moff aka the mutant quick
silver from the previously separate film
universe the fox x-men franchise
properties that are now all owned by
disney and therefore under the same ip
umbrella as marvel studios the avengers
movies
and wanavision so are we looking at the
first official on-screen crossover
between the mcu
and this x-men universe of wolverine
deadpool multiple magnetos and professor
x's
is this stunt casting in a meta joke
about sitcom recasting designed to fool
one to maximoff
and to fool us or to quote this witch a
bit of both
i'm gonna explain how quick silver got
here and what his cameo tells us about
the mcu's plans
to bring the x-men into the mcu and this
video is brought to you by privacy
privacy lets you buy things online using
virtual cards protecting your identity
and bank information on the internet as
a treat for my viewers new customers get
five dollars to spend on their first
purchase when they go to privacy.com
new rockstars to sign up now so
quicksilver has had one of the more
confusing on-screen histories of the
marvel film characters
in the comics he's a speedster mutant
brother to scarlet witch both the
children of magneto in the 90s marvel
comics sold the film rights of the x-men
to
fox studios and that first 2000 x-men
was actually kevin feige's start in this
genre he was an associate producer on
the film but quicksilver's first
appearance in these movies
technically was in 2003's x2 he and his
sister were listed as maximoff 2
on a government registry but then years
later evan peters was cast as
quicksilver in 2014's days of future
past
a pretty great film that bridges both
eras of the x-men movies
wolverine goes back in time to the 1970s
to prevent a post-apocalyptic future and
ends up hanging out with the new x-men
characters that includes them using
quicksilver to break out magneto from
the pentagon giving us this amazing time
in a bottle sequence
they do bring up magneto being his dad
but they don't dwell on it now around
this time kevin feige had grown marvel
studios from an independent studio that
would sometimes partner with other
studios and co-licensed characters to a
goliath
now owned by disney and this is just in
time for avengers age of ultron in which
they hope to feature the maximoff twins
but then fox was like
ah no way quicksilver is now our hottest
rookie so if you want to use him you
cannot make him an avenger
you cannot mention his magneto
connection and you cannot once
say the word mutant so joss whedon's
script kind of had to awkwardly use
words like enhanced for the maximoff
twins and then avoided saying quick
silver altogether
and then permanently cut off pietro's
chances of ever being an avenger
you didn't see that coming meanwhile fox
kept producing x-men movies
each set in a later decade 60s 70s 80s
90s
sound familiar well hold that thought
now the 80s set x-men apocalypse is
memorable
mostly for another quicksilver scene he
saved dozens of mutant students from the
x-mansion
as it explodes he moves at insane god
level speeds he's basically stopping
time it's all set to the eurythmic sweet
dreams
pretty cool but around this time the
tides were turning deadpool really
became the dominant moneymaker for fox
marvel studios cinematic universe was
growing more and more interconnected
it became the center of the nerd movie
universe and the last vestiges of the
old x-men brand really came to a close
with logan in 2017
and fox seeing the writing on the wall
sold all of its film rights to disney
but they had already
shot this 90 set x-men dark phoenix so
by the time they released it in 2019
everyone was like
is this still happening quicksilver is
barely in the movie
the movie's not great really you could
sense that behind the scenes the studio
was just kind of like waiting for this
franchise to die off so that they could
like sword with vision yank apart this
corpse and reboot it for bigger and
better things
and one of those projects is evan peters
crossing the stream says quicksilver
here in one division but by what
logic is marvel studios introducing the
x-men in the mcu
what does this mean well let us remind
ourselves of really the four
paths marvel might be using to reboot
the x-men and see how this quicksilver
cameo fits in with it all theory one the
explanation i think most of us are
thinking is gonna be the case
quicksilver came from the multiverse so
avengers endgame reset the mcu on kind
of an
axis of multiple branch timelines aka
the multiverse
you'll remember spider-man far from home
mentioned this multiverse but it was
then revealed to be mysterio's lie
yet the multiverse exists one division
could be part of
a multiverse saga a multi-title event
spider-man 3 will similarly cross over
characters from past
alternate universes and team up peter
parker with multiverse navigator doctor
strange
and doctor strange and the multiverse of
madness is going to be some kind of
multiverse plot based on the title
in which wanda is confirmed to return
most believe as the villain
so what we're looking at with this
westview anomaly it may be a kind of
window to that multiverse
all of its sitcom sets its props it's
costumes it's music all these aesthetics
are being pulled from
alternate dimensions that are based on
real world pop culture a dick van dyke
reality
a bewitched reality a brady bunch
reality a family ties reality and among
all of these pop culture infinite
realities one of them
is the fox x-men franchise because like
the episodes of wandavision each of
those later x-men films progressed
decade by decade
first class in the 60s days of future
past in the 70s apocalypse in the 80s
dark phoenix in the 90s so at the moment
wanda was missing her brother in this
80s episode
the anomaly plucked a quicksilver from
another universe where he was
alive in the 80s giving us x-men
apocalypse era 80s quicksilver
now this does end up being in the realm
of the explanation
anyone from that x-men franchise is fair
game to cross over
deadpool ryan reynolds who is confirmed
to have his next movie set in the mcu
magneto ian mckellen or michael
fassbender professor x patrick stewart
or james mcavoy
and by the way this could be the same
logic that explains how actors like
jamie foxx
and alfred molina are reprising their
villains in this new mcu spider-man 3.
wanda maximoff's hex bubble becomes a
sort of interdimensional pandora's box
that spills alternate universe heroes
and villains all over the mcu and in
that way
disney just ends up kind of owning
everything and again thanks to privacy
for sponsoring this video privacy is a
tool that makes it super easy to manage
your financial lives online
while keeping all of your information
secure by generating
virtual numbers privacy masks your real
bank information so that you never have
to worry about giving it out and it's
now
easier than ever to share cards with
friends and family using privacy's
shared cards
like parents can set up a monthly cap on
how much the kids can spend
businesses can send cards with
individual spending limits to employees
for company expenses
all with the security of privacy cards
and privacy comes in real handy with
recurring payments like for streaming
services i set up an account with
privacy
linked my bank account and created a
card specifically for my monthly netflix
subscription payment in case i want to
set up that subscription just for like
two more months i can set that with my
privacy card and then forget about it
like i don't have to remember to go
unsubscribe from the thing i don't want
anymore privacy will ding you
if someone tries to charge the card
again or if that charge exceeds the
amount that you set for it fill out your
credit card info and the privacy.com
chrome and firefox extension and you are
one click away from spending smartly and
safely head to privacy.com new rockstars
and sign up for an account new customers
will automatically get five dollars to
spend on your first purchase
go to privacy.com new rockstars to sign
up now but another explanation for this
mutant crossover that incorporates other
elements that keep being brought up in
one division is quicksilver's
x-men timeline bridged with the mcu
timeline
due to cosmic radiation one division has
made it clear that this westview anomaly
is radiation based
cmbr cosmic microwave background
radiation which they
state dates back to the big bang the
same event that wong explained infinity
war concentrated elements of the
universe into the infinity stones
episode 5 features monica planning to
build a vehicle that protects
from all kinds of radiation so that she
can burst through that wall radiation
including photons and neutrons which
sounds like
not just cmbr but nuclear radiation
alpha beta gamma radiation the deadlier
type of radiation that created the hulk
and radiated from the infinity stones to
injure
thanos and banner and fatally tony stark
avengers in-game also
set the rules of the mcu so that it's
supposed to be infinity stones that
cause ruptures to the time stream
creating alternate branch timelines
captain america lives out his life with
peggy carter in one of those alternate
histories
recent reports say that marvel is
developing two more films with chris
evans playing cap
and all sides point to at least one of
them following a post-world war
ii team-up with wolverine set in this
alternate history where x-men could
exist
so if the x-men do exist in an alternate
timeline
and alternate timelines are branched off
in the mcu with infinity stones
the west view anomaly a hex created in
part by wanda's powers which were
derived from an infinity stone might
also represent a convergence between
those two worlds not necessarily a pop
culture free-for-all like the first
theory really just two
slightly more plausible realities
bridging due to this infinity stone
radiation i know i might have lost you
there so
a more straightforward explanation for
how radiation could have caused this
that doesn't use the word multiverse
infinity stone radiation transformed
certain humans
into mutants so in episode 5 the moment
darcy sees pietro arrive if you listen
closely a breach alarm is blaring
through the sword camp
[Music]
so at that moment someone must have been
entering or exiting westview
this speedster we see here could be
someone from the outside strong enough
to penetrate the westview border
or at least fast enough to dart through
the bouncing particles of the border
wall again this guy's god level speed
he could be one of many individuals who
were irradiated into mutants around the
mcu
from one of those four infinity stone
shock waves because we know in wanda's
case
it wasn't just infinity stone radiation
she had a certain genetic predisposition
something that the mcu might define as
the x-gene that exists dormant in
certain individuals around the world and
has now been awakened by the infinity
stones and because this guy
is a speedster once he enters west view
the anomaly's rewriting of reality
warps him into someone wanda would
recognize
as her late speedster brother in fact
that could be why he does not respond to
the name pietro he just kind of tilts
his head with an interesting expression
this radiation mutation could be what
wanovision is hinting at with monica
rambo
her scans showed up as pure light which
could explain how she was able to
survive her violent expulsion from
westview which was something that wanda
was very surprised to see
you're still here
monica could have awoken from the blip
from the moment tony stark blasted the
universe with the latest shock wave of
radiation
and monica rambo's dna could have been
woken up to give her mutant abilities
now that would require the mcu to recon
her as a mutant as opposed to just the
superhero photon but i feel like that's
an easy switch for them to make now it
is pretty clear that wanda did not
cognitively
summon quicksilver i didn't do that
it could have been her subconscious
doing it or this cameo could have been
the doing of the forces outside of
juana's control within westview
so that is why i have posed a theory
that this quick silver
is a trick being pulled on wanda by
whatever other sinister entity is
lurking in west view mephisto the grim
reaper nightmare
whomever agnes is partnering with maybe
agnes herself
presenting to wanda a false version of
her brother
in order to appease her heartbreak after
resurrected vision is no longer doing
the trick
now this is true casting evan peters
could mean one of two things that this
entity has access to the multiverse and
is playing a trick by pulling an
alternate universe quicksilver
or reasons that have gone into another
theories or cassian evan peters could
just be
marvel's way of signaling to us that
this is not the real pietro while kind
of winking to the fans in a meta jokey
way about how sitcoms will recast
supporting roles with doppelgangers all
the time
and that less exciting version of this
evan peters would just be for all
intents and purposes just an actor with
an ironic filmography but if that's all
this
is if this is not the official x-men
crossover what will be marvel's
explanation well we have to acknowledge
folks the mutants might have always
existed in the mcu remember
we don't necessarily have to see some
cosmic event that births mutants into
existence they might have always been
there just keeping a low profile in the
background of mcu history maybe fighting
thanos's forces from other unseen fronts
of the war
future x-men titles could show us how
wolverine and cyclops the rest of the
gang confronted these crises in their
own ways
and if they ever did interact with the
avengers these are all just scenes that
happened on the side and the camera
wasn't pointed in that direction now
yeah in this case evan peter says pietro
would have nothing to do with it and
that's why i only bring it up in case
his cameo in one division isn't revealed
to be part of a bigger x-men crossover
because if that is the case this they
always existed explanation is still
very much on the table but i want to
hear from you which theory makes the
most sense to you
which would have you looking forward the
most to the mcu phase four and five you
can actually join this conversation on
new rockstar's official discord server
which you can join by becoming a patron
at patreon.com
new rockstars get our latest obsession
shirt called an unusual couple at our
merch store newrockstarsmerch.com
you can follow me on instagram at eavos
follow me rockstar subscribe to
rockstars on youtube for breakdowns of
all your wanda vision confusions
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
you